[Music]
here in our lockdown situation homebound
environment we have a really
beautiful very lucky backyard and at
night there's a motion sensor light that
goes on whenever there's a little
critter in the yard
and we've been getting a lot of raccoons
and so
christian's girlfriend maggie and i have
been leaving out some food occasionally
which you're not supposed to do
i didn't know this then they keep coming
back and you don't remember being a kid
and
and raccoons rifling through garbage
cans and the goal is to not have them
come yeah so i remember i used to put a
rock on the cans you know yeah but
they're very mischievous and they're
very industrious and they would take off
they would somehow find a way to get
into the cans and i am now doing the
opposite of what you're supposed to do
i'm
making it much more accessible you're
making it your pet yes which is what
you're not supposed to do right it's so
disgusting and you find it cute and i
find it pretty disgusting yeah well
speaking of disgusting here's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host your raccoon loving host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my raccoon
despising brother despising is too
strong of a word no you're just uh i
would just say raccoon disliking oh you
dislike them yeah how can you dislike it
you know it's it's so cute they are
that's the thing with them they have i
would say objectively misleadingly cute
they have cute faces
i can't get past
the the my memories of them as a child
seeing them rifling through garbage and
being scared of them i'm surprised
it doesn't matter how they could have
like
what would you say is the cutest animal
face uh loris okay slow loris
let's say that's the cutest or like a
little bijan dog or something like
who'd you just become i don't well i
think they're cute i don't want one but
i think they have objectively killed
yeah i guess so i just can't stand their
personalities no we're gonna get letters
their faces right just aesthetically see
i prefer the raccoon's personality they
get into things they're getting things
well they're curious they're curious
they also have a toy i like their hands
a lot they very like uh human little
opposed i don't think they have
opposable thumbs but they
they have very interes um advanced hands
don't they yeah and they're really good
at like
getting food we just have very different
opinions of so
when a raccoon comes maggie and i
scamper to the window to watch the
raccoons
you
don't care at all or you'd rather they
not be in the yard
uh i
i'd rather them not be there i guess
they remind me of like a dog like a fun
little scrappy dog like a pudgy like an
australian shepherd or a
husky or something but sure a raccoon
reminds you yeah sometimes when they're
hunched over with their haunches up i i
and they're getting into things i'll
tell you what i i i'm bothered by when
they chase they've been chasing frogs
you can see them
god forbid yeah
well agree to disagree well what about
possums do you like we get possums
occasionally oh possums
that's different
i was up at the uh cabins in
massachusetts and um and i heard this
sound
i can't do it it was like well it turned
out to be nails on
metal my neighbor had hired a trapper to
come and trap this uh porcupine that
that had been it's actually quite
dangerous for the dogs that that
neighbors that's sad i don't think you
should travel no no but they're gonna
set it free i think the trapper takes it
out somewhere okay i hope
so it was but all night and my neighbor
said he's got a really he's great i love
him but he's got a really
he's got a very unique voice and he said
yeah i just let him just leave him in
there overnight and i i all night i
heard this like
you know i felt so bad for this thing i
pictured the trapper like taking the
porcupine which by the way are really
dangerous for dogs like the quills shoot
into my my neighbor's dog has had got 18
in the nose wow for a little hopper um
but but i'm picturing this trap for like
taking
harper sorry hopper i was thinking of uh
david harper yeah oh boy well he's
rubbing your mind uh but i was because
the frogs maybe but i was
picturing this trapper like with a
porcupine like strapped in and like a
blindfold on just taking him out into
the woods so he doesn't find his way
back what's the difference between a
porcupine and a hedgehog okay good
question well a porcupine has quills
that they i think that they shoot that
are barbed and quite painful
a porcupine does yeah a hedgehog does
not so sonic the hedgehog doesn't have
that power as a character uh to shoot
quills yeah no sonic the porcupine would
so sonic the hedgehog just runs really
fast yeah that's his special thing um i
think he runs he rolls he's uh okay he
should have asked ben sure oh yeah hey
why are we talking about raccoons and
porcupines and hedgehogs a good question
well because oh i know i know too oh go
ahead well you're not supposed to feed
them period and uh another creature that
you're not supposed to feed after
midnight right are gremlins um because i
mean i'm sorry mogwai because then the
mogwai turned into gremlins and if you
haven't seen the movie gremlins we sound
like crazy people
yes yeah you probably thought we had
nerd strokes
um
he's technically but uh if you haven't
seen it you should stop this podcast
right now and go watch it don't tell
people to stop well and then and then
resume it later okay and tell your
friends to listen
gremlins classic movie from the 80s and
one of the stars of that movie of that
great classic really the star these
stars i mean phoebe cates and zack
alligators
but the the vocal star yes does the
voice of mogwai yep
is our guest today his name is howie
mandel
uh howie mandel is somebody that uh has
been in our lives because we you know
his voice has been in our lives all of
our lives and uh if you've seen gremlins
or if you used to watch muppet babies uh
or bobby's
that's pretty good really i used to try
to do when i was a kid yeah i remember
that bubbles
your sister little too he's scared like
a little cheeky too cheeky yeah yeah he
was he was living babies
and we're going to talk about where that
voice came from where his
listeners of the show know i love uh
voices
and uh so we're getting we talk about
that where they had never met him before
no no i had never met him um
uh a friend of mine was one of the girls
on a dealer no deal so she used to tell
me what a nice guy he was she
lisa was her name
she was suitcase number three i remember
yes yeah shout out to lisa i hope she's
listening um lisa's awesome and so javi
mandel has been the host of dealer no
deal for
a long time now like 15 years i think
and he's been the host of america's got
talent and he's about to start his 11th
or just did start his 11th season of
that so he is in everybody's home on a
weekly basis and everyone knows him and
and i think everyone likes him i think
so what there's not much to like about
him yeah what do you not like about
howie mendel i don't know well let's
let's hear the internet yeah maybe now
you can judge for yourself
um no he he is
okay i mean even more likable than i
expected and
uh
fascinating like has
such an incredible point of view and
story to tell and um
he was very warm and open with me so uh
let's get into it here is my uh my chit
chat your tata tet ah okay with uh
someone i really uh admire even more now
so i hope you all enjoy it with the
ubiquitous very funny very uh warm and
open bubbles
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming we'll
meet again
[Music]
where are you how are we i'm on zoom
i'm in right hey
uh oh okay yeah looks nice there what
what are they saying in la now now i
hear three months and i think as this
thing goes along we're coming up with
terminology so the stay-at-home order
was about to be lifted but the
stay-at-home order is it has never
really been a stay-at-home order well
it's an order but it's like it's safer
at home as the weeks go on these things
kind of loosen up now there's curbside
uh
you can
curbside pick up for a lot of more
restaurants than there were and for the
malls but i think what she was saying
was you know this is not going to be
lifted may 15th and then we can go out
she doesn't see it
being lifted until
august and i would imagine in your part
of the country it's been longer you're
somebody whose name often comes up in my
life because people always tell me that
i'm
germaphobic and i have i which i am to a
certain degree and i
have some i have ocd issues around that
and now i wanted to i've had a lot of
friends lately say to me you know you
seem to have been preparing for this
this time for a long time you know your
behavior would suggest that you won't be
changing that much when it comes to
interacting with people you know the the
truth is and people know me i guess i've
made it known and i've been kind of open
about my mental health issues and
[Music]
and they do uh show themselves somewhat
and and that's really a small part of it
only that's the part that has become
more known than any other part is my
germaphobe
kind of persona but and and people and i
then i've jokingly said you know you
guys are calling it a pandemic i'm
calling it told you you know
right right i'm calling it a thursday
yeah and i'm not aside from it i feel
like the rest of the world is now living
differently and i'm
nothing has really changed for me i'm
not thrilled to have been ahead of a
curve it's tough it's tough for
everybody but you know i and and
many many people deal with mental health
issues and i do so this is kind of a
roller coaster
what made you decide to because i know
you've been open about it howie what
what made you decide to to talk about it
publicly your ocd i didn't you know i i
did a i wrote a book about five years
ago and i and i revealed in my book i
was uh
about 20 some odd years ago i was doing
the howard stern show
to promote uh whatever i was doing but
he used to have more than one guest on
at a time and
the same day he had me on and i was in
the studio i think if i remember
correctly it was one of the guys from
puppetry of the penis
so
which one
i
i don't know why that makes for great
radio anyway but he was
beside me and it wasn't like this is a
podcast but at least you have zoom we
didn't even have to so
he was i assume he was from puppetry of
the penis because he was gone to his
penis and he was making sounds and doing
things that he was sitting within 15
feet yeah if he wasn't part of puppetry
of the penis he should have been they
would have it would have made sense yes
it was yeah but anyway had his member in
his uh hand and he was doing uh various
things tying it and holding it and that
but my fixation was the fact that he was
just holding his
yeah
penis his pennies
there was no uh there was no place to
kind of disinfect
and i said i got to stay away from the
couch and then i marked the spot where
he went to leave and he grabbed the door
and he opened the door and he left
and then from that time on my focus was
just on the door and how was i going to
get out of this place how do i
you know circumvent and i don't want to
be detracted by something else so i
forget where all the places which i've
kind of uh marked in my like terminator
almost
right and i had to make my way around
all these uh infected areas in my mind
oh my god so
i couldn't hear anything howard was
saying it was like one of those scenes
from the old charlie brown where they
listen
you know i couldn't hear them but
finally i heard all right well that's it
it's it's been great and thank you so
much and i got up and i kind of made my
way around where i thought the marks
were and then i got to the door and i'm
wearing uh not unlike today i'm wearing
a t-shirt with short sleeves so i can't
figure out how to grab the doorknob or
the opening to open the door so i said
to howard or whoever was there right
beside the door i said can somebody open
the door i don't want to touch the door
that guy touched it with his
you know
penis
so he so uh they said no you opened the
door i said no i don't want to open the
door so i went to go grab a tissue
did somebody have a kleenex they
wouldn't they thought it was funny they
were mocking you
yeah but i hadn't ever talked publicly
about about my about my issues they go
no open the door what are you worried
about you'll go just go open the door so
they moved the tissues away from me then
i tried to take out my like sure tail to
open the door they said no no no no try
that i went no and then
i don't know if anybody
here
suffers while people listening to from
anxiety i started having an anxiety
attack and i couldn't breathe and i
thought i was having a heart attack and
i thought i was gonna pass out and i
just quickly said howard this is not a
joke i go therapist i go to a
psychiatrist i'm medicated i have
something called obsessive-compulsive
disorder and this is i'm gonna pass out
and you're gonna i'm gonna die so you
better open the door so he kind of saw
that i was serious and they got up and
they opened the door and they let me out
in the hall and as i walked out into the
hallway
i heard the you know i thought he had
thrown a commercial i thought he had
gone to commercial
but they were still broadcasting that
whole thing
at what point you realize it's all going
out live so i realized this was going
out live i'm in the hallway you have to
realize that i'm you know i'm a lot
older than you you know i'm in my
60s i'm in my mid 60s now but even 20
years ago i grew up in the 50s and i
grew up in the 60s and the stigma and
the fact that i walked out in the hall
and i heard over the speakers that they
were still with that crazy wouldn't
touch the door and he was going to pass
out i think he's really sick and he said
he had mental health issues and he said
he's going to psychiatrist and he said
that he's medicated i heard that and i
heard it and my heart just dropped my
stomach and i thought oh my god and
three things hit me number one i've just
humiliated you know anybody who's
attached to me you know i have three
children and my wife at home i mean
they're not gonna be able to walk out
they're gonna you know that their uh
husband and their father is uh you know
has mental health problems which
embarrassing thing that one could admit
number one number two you know that's
the end of my career when there's
millions of dollars on the line for any
production who's gonna hire somebody
that you know can't get along without
being medicated or talking to a
psychiatrist so i thought
i was just devastated in the hall and
i've never been in a darker spot in my
life i just thought this is it i've just
destroyed my family i've destroyed my
career and i've destroyed myself and i'm
in the middle of manhattan we go go down
the the elevator i don't know what to do
i can't hear anything and i'm just i i
look out as i'm going across the lobby
out into the street and you know
new york city
like it used to be was just teaming with
more people i've never felt more alone
and i thought the only answer is i'll
just when that door opens i'll just run
in the traffic i gotta end this i gotta
end this and uh i walked out onto the
sidewalk and i was just looking down
and through my periphery a a guy uh came
up beside me i didn't look i didn't want
to make eye contact and he goes
are you howie mandel and i went yeah and
he goes were you just on howard stern i
just heard you on howard stern and even
more i just went like i started
countdown to go one two three i'm just
gonna jump in the traffic
and he said the two words which had a
different meaning then than they do now
but he he leaned out i didn't understand
what he was saying and he went
me too and i went what and he went you
know i i suffer
a lot also and i gotta tell you i don't
hear people talking about this and it
was really comforting so thank you
and that was kind of like a wake-up call
and at that time there was no um emails
and texting and zoom and all that so it
took about a week
after a week i got flooded with letters
and and people were saying oh thank you
so much for being so open about your
mental health and that was the
so i never decided
and then i realized for me
opposed to other people it was the most
comforting thing because nothing
uh
you know is more you know we all feel
alone and even in these times in this
you know they're using the title we're
all in this together but we're always
all in this together yeah
uh that's amazing howie i um i don't
know if people appreciate now because of
people like you
uh how
how often it's talked about mental
health issues um are being discussed now
and de-stigmatized but not that long ago
i i
i clearly remember a time where i i can
completely um commiserate with you that
that that that must have been
the thought of of revealing that must
have been overwhelmingly embarrassing
and
difficult and that's incredible um
i i i just in case people think you're
being dramatic or something you know i
mean that's no but i still think it is
you know it's really
i i've gone and spoken on capitol hill
because the um uh
mental health i think is you know as as
important as our physical health and
sometimes our mental health even is
paramount to our physical health because
our mental health you know mind over
matter you know if two people have
surgery or something goes wrong but
somebody's just you could let yourself
go you know or if you if you can garner
some mental strength or coping skills
you can even heal faster and that's
tried and proven but our uh you know our
insurance companies don't parody the
same kind of if you don't have an x-ray
you know then you can't really there's
no place to turn there's no place that's
intangible
but aside from that we must remove the
stigma you know you could sit in an
office in middle america nobody is now
but you when you can't when in theory
you can go you know what i can't lift
that my back's out and everybody will
hand you a card for their chiropractor
but you can't say i can't get anything
done today because i just can't function
i just my mind i'm so depressed i'm so
anxious i can't
do anything and people just look at you
or you can't say can i get an hour off
i've got to grow my psychiatrist i want
to make it part of our curriculum i'd
like to be an advocate for taking care
of our mental health is the same as we
take care of our dental health you go
get a an x-ray when nothing hurts and uh
you know look mom no cavities but
there's nothing in place where uh you
know even in preschool you're asked you
know questions or there's no
professional person in place
to go oh wait there's a red flag you
know i don't think gun laws are our
issue as much as you know mental health
laws well you've done a huge part uh in
taking us in the right direction there
and and
howie do you know have you been able to
pinpoint exactly where
you had mentioned that the one that
people often talk about is the is the
germaphobia and not being able to open
the door
in the case of the penis hand
uh gentlemen um
have you been able to pinpoint where
that comes from is it as simple as
because part of it is rational it's
quite rational i mean well here's what
people don't understand you know
my issue is ocd i know where the germ i
know what triggered the germ thing but
obsessive compulsive disorder i have
the same thought as
most people you know if i get you know
if a guy touched his penis and then
touched the door you know nobody
everybody's very understanding i don't
want to touch the door the problem with
me is that i can get triggered
even if i shook somebody's hand and they
they had a sweaty hand and then you go
oh my god that was disgusting i'm gonna
go wash my hand here's the problem mine
is like i guess the best analogy is like
a broken record so what happens is i you
know i wash my hand because it's icky
like everybody would think and then as i
walk away i go maybe i didn't get it all
maybe i need to back into the bathroom
and i wash my hands again and then i go
you know what the water is not hot
there's still probably some bacteria in
my head and i go back again and then i
go back again and i could go back into
there hundreds of times hours and hours
on and my life stops i miss meetings i
miss events with my family and it's like
to and and
juxtaposed to the rationale you know i
think i'm a pretty rational intelligent
being so i know what i'm doing is
ridiculous but i can't stop myself so
that's the um
it's compulsive and i'm obsessed so i
have the same thoughts nobody likes
germs nobody wants to get sick nobody
wants to touch something icky i just
can't get that skipping record
out of my head
right you don't have any more of an
aversion to strangers penises than most
people do
there are people that are well you're
using the most people some people are
just attracted to strangers that's true
that's true yes yeah it's true i uh yeah
i i does that become frustrating what
does that feel like when because i have
it to a certain extent but not
not i would say crippling um well
you know ocd really is is
is crippling ocd stops my life you know
i tell people
if you're familiar with the you know how
howard hughes ended his life you know at
the end of his life he was naked in a
room in the fetal position peeing into
bottles you know i i promise you i'm not
that
far you know i'm always teetering on the
edge of
you know just being able to function and
and thank god for you know my my amazing
family and wife and kids and grandkids
and my therapists and doctors who just
keep me going and my life is such a
dichotomy compared to how i feel versus
what i do and what i subject myself to
exactly as a known person you're very
recognizable i i people have had you in
their homes for for
decades now so
that must present a different obstacle
um
different challenges that most people
probably don't have to face in terms of
meeting new people
you know as i've gotten older and more
experienced you know there isn't anybody
that doesn't have across the bear and
there isn't anybody that doesn't have a
hurdle to get over it's just
how do you do that you know i'm
passionate about life
and i'm passionate about what i do and
you know another analogy is you know if
you love boxing you know you're gonna
get hit in the face you're gonna get hit
below the belt you're gonna be knocked
down and what is your strategy in
getting up and maintaining that energy
to move on and maybe win the race or
when the win the fight of life and life
is a fight but it's a fight worth having
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
have you been watching it reminds me of
the last stance just of that drive that
jordan had have you been watching yes
but it's amazing and that's and that's
kind when you watch that not only is it
entertaining and you're watching an icon
but i hope people take away the fact
that you know he is a human and you know
you have that drive for life or for
achieving or for doing whatever it is
you want to do you know
uh some people have more drive than
others and you don't know what triggered
that or why they're that way but i find
it very aspirational and inspirational
just to watch shows like that and say
look you can here's a guy that didn't
even make it on his high school
basketball team to become that trip from
point a not being making it to a high
school basketball team to become you
know the icon of basketball for all time
that's that's what struck me is how many
times and how many times throughout his
career he did that even after he was the
toast of chicago he they get beat by the
pistons he has to work extra hard in the
offseason to put on weight and muscle to
be tougher under the rim
and then leaving for basket for baseball
i i i i didn't think i could be more
impressed by michael jordan as a human
being um
but i i know people take away the lesson
and the lesson is not because it's
michael jordan and nike but i live by
nike's philosophy is just do it you know
and and the difference between michael
jordan and other people is
weather and we did see that in that show
a little bit you know with maybe with uh
scottie pippen a little bit but but you
know we all we all hit a point where we
get discouraged or we give up or we just
stop or we become distracted or we just
human nature and then there's people
that don't you know somebody said
you know the difference between elon
musk or steve jobs
and anybody listening to this podcast is
they did it and you didn't you know they
really did i mean they're humans like
you and me they got passionate about
something and they decided to you know
spend the rest of their life in their
garage tinkering to make something
better where you would say no no no no
no i gotta finish my classes i gotta go
get a job i gotta but he did it and you
didn't he's not that's right another
planet these these people are like you
and me
jordan has a moment where he addresses
that when he says
he addresses uh that some people the
fact that some people may think of him
as not a nice person or his legacy has
been hurt by some of the some of his
behavior uh he said anybody who accuses
me of that they haven't won anything
they haven't won
uh i thought that was really interesting
yeah oh but you're absolutely because he
you know he was kind of myopic and had
that you know that drive to move forward
i think that they give up you know
i came
you know i do stand-up comedy and
stand-up comedy is the base for
everything that i do
i got to tell you when i came out here
in the late 70s and you know my
god of comedy was richard pryor who was
uh at the at that time i watched him
every night get up on stage and put
together which i think is the seminal
you know performance of any comic on
film is live on the sunset strip by
uh richard i watched him write that
every night and
at that time you know david letterman
was the host of the who was the emcee at
the comedy store and any you know billy
crystal and all there was so many funny
people so many talented people now i
named a couple that you know there's so
many talented people
that maybe you don't know and so many
people as funny as talented what
happened they just stopped because any
of us who are doing okay in this
business
you know i i could speak for myself and
everybody that i know there is the the
amount of no's or uh negativeness versus
the amount it you know every yes becomes
a very bright light you know when i when
i go to every audition i've ever the
only audition i ever got that i
auditioned for was saying elsewhere you
know
right but everything else they said no
to me yeah so what i'm saying is that
what happens is a lot of people get no
no no no no it's not easy even if you're
great no no no and they stop so those
people just fell by the wayside they're
really talented they deserve to be
superstars they deserve to be known but
they stopped what's the difference some
people just kept doing it just do it was
there a moment where you contemplated
maybe
not doing it yeah exactly so so what
happened is at the end of
99 i did a uh i had a daytime talk show
and it failed the audience for me out on
the road kind of dried up because i
wasn't traveling for a year so i wasn't
selling a lot of tickets and then i did
a pilot i got this pilot and they
knocked the [ __ ] out of me they really
did they noted me to death and i was
really embarrassed of what turned out i
just said i can't my ego can't take this
anymore my psyche i walk i come home
every night and i don't feel good about
what i have done this is just beating me
up and then i get a call
it's in 2005 i get a call from my
manager michael and he goes you know
they want you to do a game show and i
went
no [ __ ] way you know and you have to
put yourself in the mindset 2005. there
weren't any comedians
doing uh game shows in fact the game
show host was kind of like the uh the
punch line i'm not no disrespect to hey
kind of like one of those guys here we
go like what is the talent you're
putting on a suit you uh reading a
trivia question from a card you know
like i understood the skill of acting
you know having been on a drama series
and writing material and coming up and
trying to entertain people as a stand-up
comic i didn't really understand you
know they put you in a suit and then you
go what is the capital of california can
you parody that and saturday night live
always had parodies so i went no [ __ ]
way you know what i'm already humiliated
i've already been turned down and now
you want to put a nail in the coffin of
my career i'm gonna the last thing that
people will ever remember me for is this
a ridiculous thing i get a call back
about an hour later and he goes you know
this is what they're telling me nbc is
saying
that this is a game that has already
taken the world by storm
the usa is the last to get on it so much
so on they've never done this before
this is unprecedented nbc is going to uh
give
uh
five nights prime time nights in a row
on a week to this show it's like are you
[ __ ] kidding me i just told you i'm
humiliated by this and you're telling me
that they're gonna give it coverage like
they've never got before so if nobody
remembers the howie mandel career is
over everybody's going to see it at the
howie man goodbye
third call back this is all within you
know half hour
and he says the guy won't leave me alone
he says you're perfect for it
can he just explain the game to you i go
you know i'm not going to go to a
meeting i'm not going to drive to a
meeting to be turned down or to turn
something down it's going to be negative
i'm sitting in a deli in the valley
eating soup alone that's how sad i was
eating soup alone if he wants to show up
and talk to me i'm here for another hour
he goes he's coming
boom i'm sitting there jerry's deli in
the in in uh in the valley
this guy rob smith he's with endemol
shows up and he's got like an art card
he made it looks like uh
like a maybe an 11 year old school
project like he didn't spend any money
at kinko's and now i think he's punked
you know right right right right he
moves my soup away he puts the car down
which he had done with a with a ruler
not even a straight ruler he put into 26
different things and he wrote on little
piece of paper different amounts of
money he goes pretend these are
briefcases take one don't show me the
number so i i took a and don't look at
it yourself and i took the piece of
paper he goes you think you got the
million i go i don't even know what
you're talking about he goes let's find
out if you got a million we'll open up
these and he shows me this game now
people have seen the game it's not a
game there's no trip there's no skill
there's no i'm getting soup on all half
of this [ __ ] and and just having me
there's no uh thrill in me opening up
pieces of paper that say fifty thousand
i don't even know what the [ __ ] this is
i have no this is backfiring at this
point
anyway
i go home and he goes and we can't do
this without you i go home and my wife
says my wife knew what was going on she
goes so you're gonna do it i said no
no it's ridiculous and she goes you have
to go do it and i go why she goes
because i can't stand you at home
anymore
and you know what it's just a
distraction you say your career is over
why do you care
what this does just go to work so i call
the guy and i go okay i'll do it this is
a friday i'll do it and he goes
fantastic we couldn't do it without you
i go well when do you shoot he goes
monday i go wait wait wait wait don't
you have to build a set he goes we built
a set always don't you need like 26
models they're all here how far down the
[ __ ] list was i how many people said
no you kept saying you can't do it
without me you can't do it without me
why because i'm the last one in town
that you've approached
last one in the union yes just some bald
sad guy
by himself in the valley is what you've
turned to
i settled myself by saying okay so i'm
on national tv i'm network tv i'm not
selling tickets in the club but these
are really i got some really funny
pieces that i can do and it'll showcase
that even if the game is a piece of [ __ ]
maybe people will like me
and up until this point i've only been
you know
a comedian and an actor so if i wasn't
doing material and trying to make you
laugh then i was playing a character and
trying to recite my lines this is the
first time on you know any national
stage where i threw everything
out the window i was just myself and it
was just it was my my heart was breaking
because i just wanted each person to
leave in a better place than they came
god
i've always wondered that yeah so it i
didn't so i you know and i went home at
night i went i didn't do any comedy i
didn't do any acting
i didn't really do anything witty
i did nothing and the game is nothing i
was so humiliated that i packed my
family up and i flew them ever all of us
to the caribbean because it was going to
air the next week and i thought i don't
even want to be on this continent when
this thing comes out this is the most
ridiculous thing i've ever been part of
and i get a call after the first night
of heirs from that guy rob who had the
soup with me he goes you're not going to
believe it it went through the roof i go
what did he go to the show on monday i
go are you kidding me he calls him back
on tuesday and he goes it's even bigger
on wednesday even bigger at the end of
the week 100 million people had tuned in
and they had painted my picture on the
side of the building of nbc i got on a
plane i flew back i landed in miami
within 30 seconds the first person came
up to me and went deal or no deal and i
had a catchphrase it's the biggest
success i've ever had in my life it
allowed me to open up my production
company it allowed me wow sell more
tickets there and not only that from
that point on they started calling that
the next thing was
uh on on fox they did are you smarter
than fifth grader they called jeff
foxworthy then they called louis
anderson to do family feud and now it's
a staple to see comedic
host game show so i guess what i'm
trying to say to you and i don't know if
he listens to your podcast
steve harvey you're welcome
oh yeah steve harvey is a huge fan of
the podcast you know it's interesting
because what is um what's so great about
you on the show is that you you humanize
hosting it's it's you can feel that
you're an invested part of it um you can
feel your empathy
well the network has it has got mad at
me since because they did uh
they have a show i think it's produced
by sean hayes uh uh hollywood game night
and just yeah because i'm part of the uh
nbc family they they'll
they always ask me to do it and i refuse
to do it because it's um
you know
it would be two actors and and a person
just a a contestant and i said i can't
handle my heart would break if in the
name of trying to be funny or
entertaining
we lost and that person i don't want to
be responsible for that person's winning
i can't do that it'll break my heart i'm
telling you it'll kill me that's
interesting did they ever do the
producers ever certainly in the
beginning before they knew that it was a
hit um and what you were doing obviously
worked for the formula but did they ever
try to get you to
because i i would imagine that your
natural empathetic nature would be in
direct conflict with making it more
exciting and and
they they probably want them to turn
down
this the briefcases the super well
here's where i i used to get in trouble
i used to get in trouble when it when it
got down to the nitty-gritty i love the
uh you know those those long moments
those long painful moments i think
that's what they show relatable humanity
of you know decision making but the the
truth was they used to get mad at me
we'd be like
they'd be up to an offer of you know
430
000
or you have to open two more cases
and and and i would
it's how i would
i'd say four hundred and thirty thousand
dollars cash yours
or
a chance at a million you know and i'd
kind of underlined this chance you hear
what i'm saying
this
on the teleprompters around me it would
be flashing no no no don't because they
would see that i would try to oh my god
because i would try to because i'd go
like some people do play kind of i'm not
a gambler you know i don't get yeah i've
played in vegas and atlantic city all my
life and it i don't gamble i can't
i can't it's so funny table
yeah well god it's it's so funny that
your very nature i've always wondered
that and it shows i mean this is not a
surprise to hear you say that because i
think that's part of the real charm of
the show is that there is this force
that is trying to will
them to just take it just you know do
the right thing
yeah but it's healing in the world you
know it's not like you know and we're in
a business where you know i think
there's a lot of humans that like to see
uh others fail because then their way of
kind of feeling better about maybe where
they are but i i honestly will tell you
that
nothing brings me more joy to see
somebody i care about don't care about
don't know succeed because it's just a
bright light you know and if they can
succeed i can succeed if somebody fails
it scares me this is a perfect example
of uh
it's one thing if the person has done
something i mean it's also a comedy
formula if somebody's done something to
deserve
you know their come and then they get
their comeuppance then they fail it's
you can laugh or you can maybe even
enjoy it somehow but these people on the
show for the most part they seem like
very sweet you know what maybe they're
not sweet and maybe i don't really get
to know them i get to know them as much
as the audience gets to know them but
the truth is we're all in this we really
are all in this together and uh
you know again you're saying if
somebody's not sweet if they've done
something to you then what do you want
to do you want to see them fail
even not somebody even if even if
they're
not a good person and even if they've
not done
well by me
i don't i don't wish that i just think
that that's you know i i as we talked
about at the beginning of this you know
i suffer from mental health problems and
anxiety and depression and i'm drawn i'm
like a moth i'm drawn more toward the
light than toward the dark so even
somebody i don't really have an enemy
but even if somebody was considered an
enemy i just even i don't want to see
anybody fail i really you know i i hear
you howie maybe fail was too strong a
word but i mean like i'm thinking more
of like a comedy formula like when you
know hardy would would say something
dismissive to laurel you know or he
would put him down and then he would
kind of get whacked with something or he
would then look like a fool for a moment
just the the the idea of like a
balancing uh by by getting their up and
not the other i love laurel and hardy
but but you know the the underlying feel
of that like within all that
um
uh
physical comedy and he'd get hit and and
and seeing him angry at him
the underlying tone
was the guys were inseparable this was a
great winning relationship and they
loved each other and they were best
friends so it didn't matter if they
you know i felt the same way about the
three stooges too
yeah i just love these three brothers
who were you know just
you know just mayhem ensued but if there
was real hatred or that was really
negative and it if it really existed or
if it was palpable it wouldn't have
worked
you were your parents you were talking
about laurel and hardy uh richard pryor
was an inspiration who when you were
growing up uh you grew up outside of
toronto were there other who were your
other comedy heroes who did you want to
be like and did you aspire to do that as
a job when you were younger no no i was
uh i grew up
in i'm from toronto and uh
you know i i told you i was born in the
50s so that you know i had all these
issues and anxiety and it wasn't
addressed my parents were very loving
and very supportive but i had these
issues all the time so i didn't have a
lot of
friends i didn't think about show
business i i didn't
it wouldn't it doesn't even make sense
you know i got into this on a dare i
don't know if you know my background but
uh in the 70s uh in the mid 70s you know
i didn't have a lot of friends and at
that point i think disco was all the
rage you know like studio 54 and and
they had clubs in every city you were
going to but i wasn't a drinker not a
dancer not
not a uh i wasn't really into
athleticism or gambling so you know a
couple times a week to people would show
up at the y and have a game of
basketball i i never did that i didn't
play cards with friends so when they
opened the stand up comedy club i just
went because i had never seen stand-up
comedy live and there's a the owner of
the club that's mark breslin in toronto
and it just so happened and they did
that that's yuck yucks yeah
yeah yeah how do you know yuck yucks
well i'm just doing research but i it's
still around yeah it's a big yeah it's a
big venue there it is the big venue so
so but then he said anybody from the
audience who wants to try this should
get up and
and try their wares and somebody at my
table when you should do it and i went
okay
and that's my part of my uh
it's actually one of my issues but it's
also served me well is i don't think of
ramifications i just jumped i went okay
and i just went to do that i didn't
i didn't i didn't do any uh work no
preparation
no nothing i just thought okay the joke
is i'll show up because i'm not a
comedian i'll just show up on stage and
i'll uh
i'll just uh that'll be that's because
i'm not a comedian that's the joke
that's incredible is that where the
because i read about the latex glove act
that kind of defined you well where that
came from it did if you look at if you
look at the google like my first
specials and that what happened was i
don't think things through i still don't
and and
what happened was they said ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel and i walked out
on stage thinking okay that's the joke
see i did it you said i should get up
you didn't think i was going to get up i
got up and then
in that second i looked down and you
know when you've been on stage many
times but you know the spotlight kind of
blinds you but that front row
i saw their faces and there's these
strange faces that i don't recognize and
they're waiting for me to do something
and i'm going okay i don't uh oh the
realization that fear
terror just enveloped my whole body and
i started going okay okay okay
okay all right okay and they start
giggling at my hesitation at coming up
with something okay okay and and i
didn't really understand why they were
giggling and i said go what what what
tell me okay all right okay okay and if
you look at my old
tapes that's my persona it's just this
nervous phonetic
guy who has these flailing hands going
okay all right okay okay and i put my
hands in my pocket and i have and i
actually you're on i always have i have
a rubber glove oh my god how he just
pulled a rubber glove out of his pocket
i always have them because i was always
a germaphobe and didn't want to touch
things and i always had it
the rubber glove i didn't know what to
do okay okay and i pulled it over my
head and over my nose and as i was
breathing the fingers were going up and
down and i heard the audience laughing
laughing and then i blew it up and it
popped off my head and i went good night
and and they they applauded and mark
breslin was at the side he goes you got
to come back tomorrow and when i do he
goes yeah come back tomorrow and i did
and then i just that was my place to
hang out still
life could be a dream
[Music]
i've seen your act but now of course
obviously you you write jokes i mean you
have a a more traditional planned act
when did that evolve i think of my act
and my material as a safety net any
moment or any time that i could be taken
off that path
and that's what if anybody's been to any
of my shows you know in the last little
while there's a there's a big
interaction between me and and the
audience in as far as improv you know if
there's a noise i want to
go and follow that noise if there's
difficulty if something's happening in
the room and it makes each night
different unique fun dangerous you know
and and i i go for that so i i think of
my act as a safety net and hope to be
you know taken off that path that makes
sense and and uh
considering that it's it always it's a
wonder to me that you don't do do you no
longer have aspirations to act and
things because you mentioned saying
elsewhere and i know having done now
having gone the other way going from
acting to now doing a few hosting things
how much
how important acting skills improv
skills are
in hosting um i don't know if people
appreciate that uh
do you miss scripted
series i would love that you know you
know this business we get uh pigeonholed
i i loved it you know well
you know i did stay in elsewhere i got
to announcement by accident you know
that right i i
they were shooting saying elsewhere and
um
they were six days into shooting they
had an order for 13 episodes at nbc and
they were they were
a few days in the shooting i didn't know
this i had done a young comedian special
and i had kind of hit
paydirt you know i was selling out big
venues my young comedian special was me
jerry seinfeld richard lewis harry
anderson that we were the kids and it
was host oh my god it was hosted by the
smothers brothers and then the normal
trajec
path for any comedian was once you blow
up then you get a sitcom you know
freddie prince had done it mork and
mindy had just started uh with
robin williams uh billy crystal had just
gotten soaked
so i said my my agent said you should do
a sitcom so i went to meet mt i went to
a meeting at mtm which is mary tyler
moore's company which was synonymous
with
great
half-hour comedies of the time you know
they were doing the bob new hard show
mary tyler moore show the tony wow
all these things they just started their
trek into drama they had one drama on
and that was uh um hill street blues and
they and they were shooting staying
elsewhere they i think they'd also done
the white shadow so so when i met with
the casting person she goes can you act
and i said i don't know she goes read
this and i read this side
made no sense it was all this medical
terminology she goes that's very good
come down the hall and i went down the
hall and i didn't know who i was meeting
them but it was bruce paltrow which is
gwyneth dad and mark tinker his dad
owned the company was married to mary
tyler moore and tom fontana and oh my
god yeah they had to i think you know
some of these people because didn't you
work at what's it called the theater
company and the west uh
on the coast there they all came from
the uh old globe uh la jolla old glory
no no no on your side of the country
they uh oh oh yeah williamstown
yeah they were yeah sure tom fontana and
all these guys and and yeah like banner
and you know with bruce's wife and when
it's but they all that's where so there
was this core of these theater people
that were
a totally different world than me i went
into this room and i started reading the
uh uh
sides halfway through they went thank
you
and i went home and again on a friday i
get this is a theme so this is the the
only uh
uh um audition that i was talking about
earlier i go home my wife said how'd it
go i go it went really shitty but i'll
be honest with you it wasn't that funny
because i had no context to what i was
reading i didn't know i get a call oh my
god i get a call back 15 minutes later
and they said can you go down to nbc and
meet with brandon's heartache for those
who don't know brandon's heartache ran
nbc he was the the legendary legendary
like all from every show that you ever
remember
up through seinfeld sure howie at this
point you're probably assuming that it's
a comedy i was i had no idea i go down
there and i read it for him and he goes
okay we'll see you monday this is a
friday i go
okay i thought i had another reading
monday anyways as it turns out monday i
was starting this is what was this is
what it was they had been shooting for
six days they were looking at the
dailies they were looking at the the
film from each day they didn't like
what they were seeing not that the
people weren't good they just wanted a
different tone and they wanted to recast
some of the
characters so i recast somebody and wow
here's yeah you know the original fiskus
was he went on to get an academy award
nomination was david paymer
get out of here i worked with fame no
[ __ ] yes yeah oh my god well yeah as you
said he went on to he's he's fine
saturday night he did i was so but there
again i was so thrilled because i'll
tell you anytime i bumped into him i
just was like so
devastated because oh yeah like six
years that series you know that series
was the start for denzel washington a
lot of people tim robbins did his first
shot it was ed begley
ed begley
yeah
bill that billy daniels norman lloyd who
was the uh the bad guy in alfred
hitchcock's spellbound he's still alive
he's 105.
oh my god he didn't work with judd
apatow he did well he did train wreck
right he was in trainer oh yeah but wow
yeah so so this was i and then i said to
bruce you know i'm not an actor should i
you want to get me a coach or something
he goes you've just entered the best
acting college you could ever enter and
it really was and then after that when
that started airing i started getting
movie offers and i did a couple of
movies i hated it
i hate really why because i because of
who i am and the mess of my head
i didn't like going away from home for
you know average three months at a time
i'd be in some place that i would not
choose to live
and uh
the the the
the movie making you know uh you go out
and you do two lines and they go cut and
then you go back in your trailer and you
sit there for about six hours and then
they do something else if you're doing a
comedy you know it's not shot in order
so i it's this vacuum
so it made me more neurotic i go was
that funny did that good was that good
and then i sit in the trailer and i'd go
oh i got an idea you know how i should
have done it you know how i should have
done it i go back out and they you know
100 people have moved the whole set to
another side i can't do it again and
that was that's so funny yeah
it just made me so [ __ ] neurotic i'm
sorry then so did that lead you into
another one of the reasons i i'm so
dying to talk to you about this is all
your great voice work did that lead you
into that path i know no nothing i've
done has been a path you know i just
found it found me so i was working on a
show at the same time i started uh
saying elsewhere i had this other comedy
uh
uh schedule called laugh tracks was
running at the same time which i was
doing and there's a guy by the name of
frank welker who's a buddy of he frank
welker is the
mel blank of my generation he knew that
i did these funny voices and i was doing
them in my
standup act
he introduced me first to uh
jim henson and i ended up doing uh with
him i did uh a show called the muppet
babies and of course yes you played
skeeter animal i got a yeah bunsen honey
some of my
so i did all those and then
that's great then he got a movie called
uh gremlins and he asked me to come in
and i read and i got the part of gizmo
you know and
one of my favorites yeah classic joe
dante
it's one of
the best what was that process like what
was it uh and can we hear a little gizmo
i know everyone would want that voice
when i was a little kid i was choking on
something and it's really just a virtu
you know if you took a balloon and you
and you take the nipple of the balloon
and you stretch it you know how it comes
out that
it's just air being pushed so if i block
my throat that's not my voice i'm not
doing a falsetto if i blocked when when
food was halfway down
i was going
to did yeah that that you just did it
oh my god that's it so i just practiced
that in my room got good and that's what
i would do at the back of the class so
then when i started doing stand up i
would do that
so that's that's what i did so that's
the same voice that i did
that's the same voice i did
bobby it's bobby's world bobby's world
yes and it's the same voice i did for
gizmo which is
it's the same book
that's great
oh my god did joe so you just go in the
room with joe dante is spielberg there
is
um i did not see i yeah i met spielberg
i did not see him but joe joe was there
i remember when i went up
frank got me uh a meeting to go um
to be cast for it to audition frank oz
uh but but uh no frank welker or frank
welker i'm sorry yes so he got me and
the casting person for the voiceover was
in a building in in uh burbank and the
building housed a um
they just you know rented a an office
but the next office next to where they
were casting the voice people for
gremlins was a an ob gyn was a
gynecologist
and i remember going up the stairs and
hearing
a woman going no
no
no and i don't know what kind of
procedure she was getting but i i
thought that that was the audition
use your imagination
then i can only imagine if that's what
that sounded like to them right you're
going into
you're going into and i'm not talking
about the gizmo because it was all the
struggles oh like stripe yeah
i did some of the background
that sounds like an episiotomy to me
[Laughter]
well maybe it was comforting to them
it's like well as uncomfortable as this
is god knows what's happening next door
sounds like someone's stuck in a
microwave
yes um
that's great oh man
what a thrill that is and how did you so
when you so when you're doing the muppet
babies does it just because i think
frank oz did some of those voices anyway
animal at least but did no i was adamant
babies he did the muppets no no i know i
know but i'm saying the yeah the adult
the older versions did they
did you have to work with them to get
the voice down
well it was a one of my uh favorite
thrills was sitting with the jim jim
hanson
that then we table read it like you
would a movie you know and
we talked about it and he talked about
how he saw the character and how he saw
the voices and that was really exciting
i'm a huge jimmy and i don't know if
you've noted like over at 30 rock did
you ever go to that uh when you do uh
fallon or
whatever
show you did on that floor did you ever
see where jim henson was waiting to do
the
tonight show with jack parr where he
painted the pipes
no i don't think so okay so if you if
you ever get a chance if this world ever
opens up again if you go do jimmy fallon
or you're on a tour at nbc at 30 rock on
the same floor where
uh seth is and and and
there's a no
snl well snl's on a different floor
right isn't it
but on the same floor as fallon if you
go down there's all the dressing rooms
and then if you make a right they kept
this little area and when jim hansen was
a young puppeteer and he got his first
shot on on the jack par show at the time
the tonight show at the time
he was sitting there they had to come in
early and they did some rehearsals and
he was sitting there and the wall was
open there was no drywall on the wall
and he painted
all these great characters by hand on
the pipes
and now there's a plaque there where you
can go this is and it's the date that he
was there how many oh wow and you could
see all the characters hand painted on
the pipes in 30 rock howie that's so
cool i i hate that i'm running out of
time with you because those voices were
such a big part of my bobby's world i
watched all the time and we have a
lightning round what is your most
commonly used emoji howie
my own face
ah okay if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
running
away if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be chocolate yeah any particular kind no
i don't i'm not discerning i just i love
chocolate my
most clear uh recollection of even being
a child is wishing chocolate was
the meal that i could live on chocolate
and say if you don't finish your
chocolate you know
more chicken
right yeah that's the dream
uh if somebody with penis hands touched
a piece of your favorite chocolate and
then gave it to you
i imagine you wouldn't take it but it
might be tempting um it depends were
they circumcised oh that's what it
depends on well
right that's true uh what's what is uh
what's your favorite movie of all time
and i often get shamed for this so feel
free to my favorite movie of all time
it changes it always i don't have all
time you know for years and years i love
the graduate
oh yeah oh god yeah
or now in quarantine how is there one
that you find yourself
like comfort watching well
everything's comfortable my wife and i
just finished uh watching everybody's
doing big watching we just finished um
oh
netflix so now we're moving on to hulu
oh you finished the whole platform
netflix i did wow good for you a movie
on netflix i uh
watching defending jacob right now i'm
really enjoying that uh if you could
live somewhere else where would it be
you mentioned the caribbean in a bubble
when i was a kid the boy in a bubble and
i thought this is not a problem this is
a vacation yes
um if you could have dinner with three
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met you you mentioned what a
thrill it was to meet certain people who
who would you like to sit and have a
meal with who you maybe didn't get a
chance to i would say alive because
having dinner with three dead people
is just gonna be boring right and
depressing imagine what and the odor i
mean how do you right could you pass the
salad
i said could you pass the salad
that's okay i'll get it yeah
yeah okay a lot i thought it was alive
okay um
would jim henson be up there with maybe
one of the uh
stooges yeah it would be or the marx
brothers i was a big marx brothers fan
and i have two brothers myself yeah
i do a show which i want to promote on
your podcast
26th the agt came back yes you know
season 15
and season 15 okay wait uh may 26th um
[ __ ] i have so many questions about that
too america's got talent um
you've been doing it for how long now
i've been doing it for 11 years
it's the best job i've ever had because
i am watching people's dreams and hopes
come to fruition right you know 25 feet
in front of me and it's full and you
know i was a big fan of the ed sullivan
show and this is the the incarnate of
the ed sullivan show variety if you
don't like what you're watching wait
another you know two minutes and you'll
see something else completely different
in a different category
i love it and i love the people i'm
sitting with you know this year i'm with
sofia vergara
came back and simon came back and this
is so that's that's really exciting i
love simon i was always a fan of his and
uh how critical he was but is that
difficult for you i imagine that you are
the
obviously the less critical of the two
but is it difficult for you when are you
ever tempted to be more critical and you
and your own empathy just gets in the
way
every each and every day and not show
but in life with my
with the with every yes you know that
was the hardest part but then i realized
that you know
i'm there to be you know i hope that i
can be constructive and you know you can
be critically constructive you know and
i think when you have an opportunity
this is a hard business as you know and
to kind of make and break yourself in
and if you have people who've been there
for a while and have something
constructive not just destructive to say
you know i think simon cowell kind of
broke the mold as far as we always had
these talent shows you know we had star
search and we had right you know things
out there
but the the truth is that i think that
he was the first person to just be
honest and if you know
if you know simon cowell if he saw that
somebody was hurt or taken aback by what
he saw as soon as they said qatar as
soon as we go to commercial he's the
first one to jump up on stage and give
them a hug and go no
i just make your choice is wrong or
maybe this is not for you but he makes
sure that they're comforted they leave
the building
comforted he was honest totally and
that's uh yeah you're right and and and
i love seeing that i i really value
honesty and uh that doesn't surprise me
that he behaves that way that he goes
over and comforts i i can see that
because he doesn't seem like a mean
person and i think oftentimes people
conflate those two he's probably one of
the warmest silliest guys i've ever met
he really is that's not his persona on
the show but it is that's good to hear
and we mentioned it earlier we talked
about it but in this business i think
that is important for people to be uh
honest for people to be
critical and i also want to mention that
i i produced the show
it's coming out on quibby on may 25th i
think it starts it's called it's kirby
and i don't know if anybody follows on
instagram but uh kirby jenner who is uh
kendall's
twin brother
oh okay
kendall uh
jenner uh-huh okay and that's called
it's it's called kirby on quibby it's on
quibby you know that's that new mobile
app but well if you go on instagram
right now and you look up kirby jenner
yeah he's brilliantly funny he's so
amazing he's the kardashian that has not
been
you know the world hasn't been
introduced to yet and he's got this huge
following on instagram and
me and uh
mcgee
and uh kendall produced this show for
quibby so you gotta you gotta watch wow
okay cool i can't believe there's a
kardashian that the world has not been
introduced to yet
um well we i did it
yeah yeah okay well thanks i guess is
that it are there more are there any
left
not found but we're looking
okay okay if there are any uh
kardashians listening that have yet to
become pop pop culture figures uh well
howie i could talk to you all day this
has been so enjoyable uh really quick
howie i've been curious about this um
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia
um
i'm a golden guy what is it
betty white sophie sophie so
i think that's rose
what's what's betty's name
rose yeah rose i know i like
like rose i'm kind of a airhead kind of
a fun
my wife is telling me who i am
what does she think you are who does she
where do you think i am really be arthur
dorothy i would have guessed it dorothy
yeah
sorry
she she knows better than anyone i'm
sure
40 years
40 years i read that too i wanted to
talk to you about that there were too
many things
yeah
um good for you both uh what a pleasure
this was howie thank you my pleasure i
hope we get to
see each other in person one day i hope
we get to work together
i would love that
uh i love that voice
you kind of look like bobby when you do
the voice really you're like
yeah i forgot about him he he i get him
sometimes confused he looked a little
bit like uh on family guy the
the baby didn't he look a little bit
like am i getting that wrong he had a
baseball i haven't seen bobby's world in
a long time the baby on family guy
yes the one who him oh yes i don't think
so no maybe he looked more like um what
did he look like like a little boy like
an all-american boy like yeah
yeah like a kid you would see in like a
textbook of just like a boy yes yeah i
think i think so too but it's been a
while i've always felt a kinship with
howie mandel ever since like learning
that he was germaphobe because i
consider myself a bit of a germaphobe
and someone who has
ocd i but
to find out hearing from him it's
hearing him talk about the ocd i
realized that
my version of it is
much less extreme than his which i know
he even he made it sound like it
wouldn't technically even be qualified i
don't know if yours would be i don't
know i don't know the extent of yours i
know you've talked about having
germaphobia but i have legitimate ocd
things where like what is how does it
matter i i remember the other night we
were at the lake and i mean i know i'm
just asking were you thinking about this
i was like i wash my face
yeah that's right same way every time i
wash my face yeah that's the exact same
like strokes with my hands and i do the
same thing i have certain routines that
i have to do and if i don't do them i
feel like i'm not doing it right you
have to touch things a certain number of
times yeah but he sounds like
it's a real struggle it get really good
in the world in the back that he is yeah
i know but like i would have a hard time
when you told that the pup tree the
penis guy touching the doorknob i would
have a hard time a really hard time
touching that but i would do it you get
over it to get out of the room
i'd use my shirt isn't that what he did
no he explained why he couldn't do that
for some reason he started i think he
started to untuck his shirt tails and
yeah they were like no just open it just
do it and they kind of wouldn't let him
use his shoes i've done that before i
mean before this whole pandemic now of
course everything's changed but i
remember doing that uh using my shirt to
open doors or to touch buttons and stuff
i would do it definitely if i knew i was
going to be eating something with my
hands you know i would make sure i would
be very aware of um and i remember
feeling
shame uh a degree of shame if somebody
would catch me doing it speaking of
germs yeah how crazy is puppetry of the
penis oh my god you have you seen it no
but i've i've seen it you have yeah i've
always kind of wanted to but i've always
seasoned two tickets
no i went i saw a video of it somewhere
should we explain what it is oh yeah i
don't know don't people know no maybe
not i don't know if everyone knows this
it was a show in new york right and i
think it may have started in australia
oh really which
i may be making that up because
as far as i know it's an off-broadway
show
yeah uh where australians are known for
playing with their penises where men
uh
manipulate their
genitals in different sort of clownish
ways like like you're making like
balloon animals like balloon animals yes
but not at a kid's party right where
they like turn it inside oh it's crazy
stretch but haven't you done stuff like
that i mean like
in the way that you know people are
listening right no but like
if howie mendel has true ocd
and compared how he meant out to like a
real uh puppet puppetry of the penis uh
what would you call someone in that
master of the puppet master of the penis
um a puppet master of his own domain
yeah that's good but uh haven't you done
vert i mean who hasn't played with you
know done shapes and stuff shapes well
you see what you can do with it you
especially like the woman
the woman of course the the purse alien
brains alien brains the the i like the
per the where you put everything in the
purse what is that it's you just put it
on yeah i don't i've never heard that
yeah the furry murray what's the free
murray
oh is this a slippery slope
anyway i've always wanted to see that oh
yeah i'm surprised you've never seen it
why are you so surprised by that i don't
know you like penises i'm not fascinated
by penises
you like puppetry
you like you love penises no but there's
uh it's it's actually really i mean this
not in a
gross way it's really cool what they're
able to do
with their things or their schmecks yeah
it is i would would like to see it at
some point
i wish you had asked him what he would
want to replace the handshake with oh my
god i know i bet
that was one of the questions on the
list it's one of the i know howie mandel
popul popularized the fist bump on
dealer and odile yeah i would always
been i've always been grateful to him i
wanted you to ask him this too
if between the fist bombs like between
setups on the show he has to go wash his
hands
i am genuinely so mad at myself that i
didn't get into that with him you know
you guys were talking about the jordan
documentary and he was you were both
admiring i got to stop talking about
that with your guests
constantly you were both admiring his
but in this case it drew an interesting
conclusion um because you were talking
about he he was
marveling at his
drive and his passion and
he was saying that basically that's how
successful people
yeah they're talented but they also
never give up they just keep adding keep
adding keep at it he then told the story
about how he didn't want to do deal or
no deal and he wanted to give up and he
was right he kind of wanted to pack in
his own career so honest honest to admit
to that honest but surprising for
someone who has
such a um who's driven and has such a
passion well for
life and being in show business that it
got to the point where his it's a great
story but it got to the point where his
wife had kind of forced him to do it and
obviously he's thankful that he did
mandy mendel yeah yeah i um
shh that's a great story too just i
always love hearing that when people
have been married especially in
hollywood for so long but you know i
don't know if you're remembering and i i
have vague recollections of howie mendel
pre-deal or no deal
he
was like
i hate using this term but like
he hadn't you know like
i don't what would you call like a
has-been or like he had that kind of um
[Music]
stink
he felt it he did it yeah yeah yeah oh
god it's like
someone using an offensive term it's an
offensive show business room but i feel
like i can use it because i've been
there i mean i know what that feels like
to like go from have great success to
right just kind of because i'm just
having a podcast
it's funny though like it just shows how
it shows how absurd and
crazy show business now to go from
saying like i don't want to do the show
and i'm i'm so embarrassed that i shot
in the first episode
that i'm gonna bring my family out of
the country because i don't want to be
there when it airs yeah then five days
later 100 million
it was an overnight faces on billboards
i mean it was an over week it was an
overnight is like a misleading it was an
over fortnight session yes yeah but he
um i i also found it really interesting
that his strength on that show what came
to be his strength and why he's so such
a great host for that show is that it
had very little to do with his
comedic gifts i mean not very i
shouldn't say that no it had less to do
with this comedic gifts and more to do
with his
his empathy yes he just how connected he
was that was interesting that the
teleprompter they were saying like no no
no don't don't don't don't convince them
to it makes sense take this deal makes
sense
for financially and it makes for a
better tv yeah if they turn down the
deal that show is always
i i i i feel that the stress the stress
of it and i always got the impression
that he really
wanted them to
do well succeed and not i mean clearly
not lose at all and of course that
really came across yeah
it's interesting that he um illustrates
that with effort he still remembers the
first contestant
um and i that's as he was saying that it
was a feeling it was a familiar feelings
i watched a lot of that show
and i would often have that feeling
which was
you kind of fall and
you get to like the contestants and like
you hear a little bit of their story and
they seem excited and like they're gonna
they're into it and
and then they start get the greed starts
to take over and you you think don't do
it like this could change
you could use this money well you've
seen versions of that when you're
gambling in vegas when the people you're
at a table with are are making really
bad decisions and and are you thinking
of someone yeah and you uh and it's
maybe a future guest it's maybe
hopefully it's heartbreaking to see i
know until they get uh an iconic tv show
and uh
start making millions of dollars so they
can afford to go to vegas
decisions should we we shouldn't say
we're talking about but um a friend of
ours great guy uh yeah he would he was
just making crazy swings at the table i
actually remember falling in love with
blackjack when i was i was on a trip to
vegas with uh an ex-girlfriend and she
left she went back to la and i and my
friends from we're coming from you can't
handle your gambling no no we we were
doing it together it was so we were
having so much fun and but i had like
not quite 24 hours on my own
between her leaving and my friends
coming in and uh
they came to meet me
at the table i was so excited to see
them some of them like togo and nick
pines i hadn't seen them in a while and
um and i was i got so into blackjack
that
i i saw them coming in the casino they
saw me i waved over them and i was just
so consumed by the game
that when they came up to me they were
like dude what's up and they and i i
wouldn't even get up to to greet them
because i was still in the middle of a
hand i was like
hold on one second
and they togo said later that i was like
a cross between it was like uh jackson
brown and gollum had a baby i was all
like hey nick was like you're like
howard hughes you're all like pale and
like long hair and like i've been there
that's really and you you have to shake
yourself out of it but it
i i i
see how people get addicted to gambling
yeah i i felt that that uh draw before
that really it's kind of scary it's
scary i know and like you don't want to
work
when you're doing well and it's so
devastating when you're not and you ride
this crazy roller coaster yeah crazy
wave like any drug i guess yeah i guess
so he was talking about getting his
start in show business and and how
he he
kind of did things without thinking
about them and he just kind of jumped on
stage and on a dare just to like do it
and seem like a person but it struggles
to seem like the same guy
who has ocd and obsesses over things and
over if anything i would think that kind
of guy would overthink
uh getting up on stage yeah but but he
clearly doesn't and and as illustrated
by the lightning round where he didn't
put any thought into any of his answers
did you notice that it was just like
first thing that came to his mind oh my
god and if nothing came to his mind he's
like i don't really care about this
question yeah next one you're right and
for an ocd person that surprised me
because i would i and maybe i'm
stereotyping ocd people but it seems
like
that type of person would really think
through their answers well that's your
type of ocd maybe maybe but also i
aren't you i'm so curious now just to go
back and look at some of his early
stand-up stuff because he made it sound
like
he was just winging it and like his his
the charm was that he didn't know what
he was doing and
i'm sorry that can't i mean i'm sure i
know it evolved from that but i'm
curious to see how it evolved because he
said he was uh he was up there with he
mentioned a couple other comedians like
jerry seinfeld and well that's once he
had made it once yeah that's not when he
started out when he first started out he
he got popular by doing that thing gag
with it with the rubber glove also
germaphobe i wouldn't even apparently he
did that bit so many times i was reading
that it messed up his
nose like the cartilage in his nose or
something like blowing it out and he had
all this damage in his like a cocaine
yeah oh my god
it's also crazy that story about how he
got seen elsewhere how he thought of
crazy stories crazy yeah
and that was his only
real
act i mean that was the he said that was
the only audition he ever got it's wild
um let
us read a letter um you know i love this
last name and then it continues on to
this oh okay kim mcclure what does that
make you think of that last troy mcclure
oh troy mcclure but i think mark mcclure
oh from superman superman back to the
future okay kim
says subject hello and would you
rather's from amsterdam
i'm so mad at myself that i was in
london for so long and never went
hey justin and christian i'm listening
to your latest episode whilst standing
in a socially distanced queue i also
like that word for line
i like amsterdam queue outside the
bakery in amsterdam
things are weird here sure but life is a
lot more chill than it seems in some
parts of the world no one wears masks
we've been told not to to ensure there
are enough for healthcare workers
families are out people are exercising
in the parks it seems the dutch are
approaching kova the same way they
approach everything with pragmatism the
numbers of infections here are really
high but being outside right now you
never think it well the sex shops are
closed at least oh that makes sense
um but i'm super grateful to be able to
go for a walk every day especially when
i can listen to your podcast
oh
thank you kim uh continued but that
doesn't mean life isn't hard every time
i hear you guys in your banter hilarious
i think of my sister that was her
commentary not ours i think my sister
who's back in my home country south
africa she's my best friend in the world
and i long for the day when we can sit
together again and laugh the way you
guys do
man that's just a long way away from
amsterdam i miss her and my parents more
than anything i feel like i'm living in
two worlds because i'm a south african
expat living in amsterdam and the
lockdown is almost non-existent here
whereas they're having a hard time in
south africa with a really restrictive
uh lockdown you can't even buy alcohol
anywho some
ywrs why i mix those i'm mix those
letters and your eyes just spasm well i
have a little bit of dyslexia with those
letters why wr would you rather's why wr
watch your parent oh god i hate this one
you mean w-y-r w-i-r you did it wrong
twice twice
i have an issue with those two letters
w-y-r okay you don't have to be so
okay this i don't even want to read this
what
her first one w
would you rather watch your parents have
sex for one minute
or they have to watch you have sex for
one minute
sorry mom and dad but i'd much rather
than rather me me too
much rather
not much rather much rather yeah i guess
so much rather yeah in fact i would
rather them watch me for an hour
than me watch them for one minute
do you know they're watching you yeah
yes uh i would have it would be very i
don't think i could do it okay how would
you do it
um would you rather have freely roman
would you rather freely roaming eyebrows
what is that just like they're moving
going on that's what i picture them
going all over your face freely roaming
so they can just keep they're rolling up
and down your face or just they stay in
place were there but they're moving i
move my eyebrows a lot uh like graphics
yeah you have control over them yeah
they're not freely roaming
or grasshopper legs yeah did you look at
your legs and think they kind of already
are
skinny yeah a little area but can i do
things that grasshopper can i hop like a
grasshopper she doesn't say but um can i
i'm asking you
yeah
no then i definitely take the
grasshopper yeah me too then i would
wear long hair i would wear long pants
all the time and hop all around
compared to a human body
if you could hop like a grasshopper
it'd be a i mean you could hop over
buildings it'd be amazing it'd be a
superpower yeah yeah all right take the
grasshopper legs yeah yeah i take the
grass yo i take those grasshopper legs
for real would you rather sneeze every
time you think about someone sexually
and everybody knows it
or
not be able to tell a baby from a muffin
so i imagine it works the other way so
every time you see a baby you want to
eat it i would say right now in my life
since i don't have a baby
i would rather not be able to tell a
baby not tell the difference but also
because i can control myself it's not
like every time i see a muffin i need to
eat it exactly willpower when it comes
to muffins i'm not a big muffin fan if
you're if i'm missing oh see i am oh
yeah i love a muffin but i but i don't
need to eat a muffin that's in front of
me what's your favorite kind of muffin
cranberry
i didn't think you're going to say that
you said that you tried you
overcompensated for how uh
that sounds how soft that sounds you can
cranberry
uh i think you're gonna say like
chocolate chip or no bran even no i like
blueberry too blueberry that's right i
thought that was your but it's
rare to get a really good cranberry
we're at cafe taza where the coffee shop
we used to work at yeah they would get
these which is probably a healthy habit
i know sad
it sounds like to catch a predator
to catch a healthy predator
uh they used to we used to get delivered
every morning these delicious muffins
and the cranberry muffins were these
warm with these big
juicy cranberries in them i've never
you're gonna make fun of me for this but
i've never been a fan of like
fruit and warm baked goods because it's
um
because
because it to me it's like one or the
other i like i like my fruit kind of
cold and you do not get it uh so you
would rather sneeze i mean the muffin
the baby muffin uh yeah because i'd be
able to control myself but if i ever had
a baby i would change it i would rather
um sneeze every time i thought something
sexually and everyone knows that that's
the scary part i mean god forbid you
i would be sneezing all the time not
because i think everyone's actually i
wouldn't be able to it's like not it's
like you have a
you know it's like farting but this also
imagines a world where i never sneeze
any other time oh what if i'm just an
allergic person and people are confusing
yeah that's my sneeze between
um
yeah that's funny
if i couldn't tell a baby from uh honey
mama shout out um then that would be
tricky that'd be tough
because i love honey mamas well if you
think more than muffins if you think a
baby is a muffin and you're hungry and
you see a muffin you start and you start
you go to eat it you just couldn't eat
muffins anymore not only that but you
would
you would get into a lot of you'd end up
eating a baby you started no one was
around yeah but then you imagine if
there was a baby around
the baby's caretaker would be there too
and they'd they'd be like whoa whoa
of course i i know a lot of these things
are ridiculous but think about this like
if you really did have this affliction
you'd see like you'd be like why are all
those babies piled up in that display
case at a coffee shop you're
overthinking it i know okay uh would you
rather pee i'm doing what how he meant
at the opposite eye mandel would you
rather pee yourself every day once a day
for the rest of your life or
feel like you need to pee feel like you
need to pee for the rest of your life
all the time wow hey
definitely a definitely a
can you control when you pee yourself
because i would just be like oh i don't
care i don't care even if even if it was
at a dinner party
even even if i couldn't wear a diaper
having to pee all the time and life
sounds like a nightmare to me i guess
you'd get used to it too i wonder how
used to it you again i ca it's hard for
me to think or have a conversation or do
anything when i have to i know it's true
well it depends i guess it depends on
also what degree because i can push
myself like on a road trip or something
i can too but it's really uncomfortable
but i'm saying this is this hypothetical
at the end you're about to pee yourself
that's impossible uh these are great kim
i know she says this is back to kim's
letter i know these are life's great
questions thanks for the laughs sending
laughs sending a distanced hug
thank you kim those are good kevin great
kim thank you so much we love getting
those letters and would you rathers um
both combine into one letter or just uh
separate yeah that was great um and
our email address oh sorry is life is
short at wondery.com also so interesting
to hear about people from different
parts of the world how
how covet is affecting those societies
different societies um
so interesting and again feeling like uh
i just feel connected to somebody in
amsterdam is cool
don't you want to go there i would like
to go there someday i've never been yeah
so thanks kim and thank you to the great
hilarious ah howie mandel what up i am
just so happy we got to talk to him um
and check out how we show uh
jenner kirby jenner kirby jenner on
quibby and america's got talent yes i
will be watching with simon cowell i
also like what he said about simon
cowell that he's a nice guy yeah i've
heard that before oh really i've always
liked him and yeah and his honesty again
that'd be great to talk to him on the
show scary
a little bit no you know he's nice it
would still be intimidating it would be
because i also think he's very bright
and uh and honest honest to the point
where if he thinks it's a stupid
interview he'll be like are you serious
yeah alec baldwin got a little bit like
that which is it can be like alec
baldwin interview is yeah stop there for
me oh he's that one a lot he's the best
um
okay well thanks everyone too for
listening and uh stay tuned for a voice
memo and we'll see in a couple days
that's right
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long and produced by megan
monaco senior producer is michelle miesh
lans audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall
louie
and ernan lopez for wandery bye
thank you for listening
[Music]
but i want like
oh maybe the outside will be oniony
so the inside is just a raw onion
basically it's like a cold raw onion and
then the layer outside the inside
is like a warm raw onion which i like
sucking on
oh gross
it's like
it tastes like dead skin
it was it tastes like i'll tell you what
it tastes like it tastes like older
sometimes cooking leaks
what a failure what a failure it tastes
like
the exterior looks the most delicious it
looks crispy yeah like the very outer by
the way layer
i could have told you that i popped a
piece of my mouth
oh legs
it was like dries yeah it tastes like it
tastes like old rainy
grill rack you know that hasn't been you
know that that uh smell yeah
whatever you need like an old rainy
grill house it can't taste like that
yeah
well it's like it's like old ashy i hate
to say this that's basically what it is
i mean the outsiders there's raining i
just rubbed my teeth together and it was
like
old like pieces of charcoal
gross
disgusting yeah yeah i didn't i gotta
say i'm sorry i didn't clean it um i
didn't clean the grill as well as i
should have or at all no i did i did you
know no i did you know it's funny to
imagine
if james was still here
he didn't shake himself out of the house
he laughed
this next layer is disgusting too he's
left
every layer is a different level i guess
so lesson learned you can't just throw a
leak on a grill
oh
this represents that's the whole leak
master the whole league
these sections of it
all different
first layer second layer third or fourth
layer inner layer
are all disgusting
in different ways
we've described so the first one you bit
was there was this layer was the one
that tasted like the wet grill
and i couldn't chew through it even
though it looks the most delicious
it basically is i mean it's been on it's
a thin membrane of
a vegetable it's been on a grill i keep
getting a little like crunchies notes of
last week's uh hamburger
or like last springs cheeseburger
that's more what it tastes like
you